Doct je suis navré pour votre femme
c'est épouvantable Laura c'est ça est-ce
qu'elle va
mieux vous êtes de la police
non non
mais il y a quelques années j'ai vécu à
peu près la même chose que ce que vous
devez vivre en ce moment ah oui
oui le type qui a violé votre femme
avait été libérée sur parole il y a 3
semaines de
vous savez qui c'est il l'avait déjà
fait et il recommencera si vous
voulez on peut s'en occuper pour vous
comment ça vous vous en occupez
l'arrêtez vous
voulezer oui mais si on le livre à la
police ils vont certainement faire des
tests et ça va prendre au moins 6 mois
ensuite il y aura un procès votre femme
en admettant qu'elle n'est pas renoncée
à sa plainte va se retrouver encore une
fois plongée dans ce cauchemar devant un
jury elle devra répondre aux questions
des avocats et même si le procureur
arrive à établir les fait ce qui n'est
pas garanti le violeur peut très bien
sortir au bout de 11 mois n'importe qui
peut prendre le double pour Fr
fiscale qui
êtes-vous je m'appelle Simon